[Musica]
buonasera a tutti ea tutte
io mi sto chiedendo in questo periodo se
effettivamente alla plastica sia il
problema più grosso che abbiamo dal
punto di vista ambientale e se
effettivamente il plastic free con
movimento molto di moda in questo
momento sia effettivamente la soluzione
di tutti i nostri mali chiaro la
plastica è un problema lo vediamo tutti
qual è il problema della plastica almeno
questa è la parte più visibile del
problema è un problema che ci stiamo
trascinando avanti da decenni dal
secondo dopoguerra
da quando la plastica è diventata
appannaggio di tutti è diventata un bene
di massa sostanzialmente sono che il
problema si sta accumulando e
soprattutto si sta accumulando
nell'ambiente è uno dei problemi della
plastica grossi è che non sappiamo molto
quello che succede nella parte non
visibile questa è la parte visibile
nella parte non visibile ovvero le
microplastiche o peggio le nano
plastiche non sappiamo ancora bene la
ricerca scientifica ancora un po
indietro e quindi dobbiamo andarci un po
attenti ma il problema della plastica
fa parte di un problema più grosso che è
quello dei rifiuti
il programma dei rifiuti è sicuramente
un problema di smaltimento e qui vedete
nella foto lo smaltimento che avviene
purtroppo ancora in paesi terzi e con
coinvolgimento di minorenni con problemi
di salute
di conseguenza con problemi ambientali
eccetera però è un problema più grosso
che coinvolge il cosiddetto zaino
ecologico cioè noi e buttiamo un oggetto
nella pattumiera ma non stiamo buttando
buttando soltanto quell'oggetto stiamo
buttando tutto quello che ci è servito
per crearlo quindi tutte le materie
prime che ci sono servite per farlo
tutti i trasporti che sono stati
utilizzati per portarlo in giro nel
negozio e poi a casa nostra eccetera e
tutta la co2 emessa per cui non è solo
un oggetto che buttiamo è un un'enorme
quantità di cose che stiamo buttando
quindi la plastica può effettivamente
essere un materiale sostituito da altri
materiali comunque usa e getta
ci sto riflettendo mi sono imbattuta in
uso in uno studio danese della agenzia
per la protezione dell'ambiente danese
del 2018 che ha messo a confronto tutta
una serie di borse della spesa di vari
materiali bio plastica plastica cotone
organico classica riutilizzabile
eccetera
e l'ha fatto tramite un sistema che si
chiama e si chiama 6 lca life cycle
assessment cioè un sistema
standardizzato per calcolare il peso
ambientale di un determinato prodotto
dalla culla alla tomba
che cosa emerso da questo studio che la
borsa che vedete alle mie spalle è la
borsa a più basso impatto in assoluto
fantastico io e tutto quello che ho
fatto fino adesso di andare con la mia
sportina a fare la spesa da brava a
portarmela da casa tutte le volte senza
dover per forza prendere al vostro
soggetto o sbagliato
secondo questo studio apparentemente sì
nel senso che per
riuscire a equiparare il peso ambientale
di questa borsa che viene utilizzato una
sola volta
riutilizzata come bidone della
spazzatura e poi incenerita occorre
utilizzare 20mila volte la borsa in
cotone organico
20mila volte
io credo che nella mia vita non sarò mai
in grado di utilizzare 20mila volte una
borsa in cotone organico
quindi sono rimasto sconvolto da quello
che è emerso da questo studio allora ho
cercato di capire studiare e ho riletto
lo studio e mi sono accorta che in
realtà loro usano di riff come
riferimento questa borsa che hanno
determinato
determinato determinata dimensione e
contiene un determinato volume
la borsa che hanno considerato è una
borsa che stava insieme alle altre che
hanno considerato nel mondo determinata
a catena di supermercati nel 2017 in
danimarca quindi erano solo quelle borse
in quel determinato contesto che hanno
considerato la borsa che hanno
considerato loro era più piccola per cui
i calcoli che hanno fatto l'hanno fatto
per su due borse quindi da 20.000 dal
peso di 20 mila io direi che possiamo
anche scendere a 10.000 è comunque
numero enorme non sto mettendo in
discussione questo studio per carità
però diciamo che considerando altri
contesti magari il numero di i o
studiano altri altri parametri cambiando
i paragoni magari il numero di borse di
volte che deve essere utilizzata la
borsa in cotone potrebbe essere un po
più vicino alla realtà diciamo
un'altra cosa che non considera questo
studio o comunque una cosa che ci serve
ci serve sapere nel momento in cui
dobbiamo decidere se scegliere la
plastica o sharon scegliere un altro
materiale
ma come ho detto prima che la plastica
la brutta abitudine di
degradarsi in pezzettini sempre più
piccoli questo non è un problema nel
momento in cui la buttiamo dove io e
dove voi buttare l'immondizia cioè nel
posto dove deve stare il bidone
nel caso della plastica differenziata
ovviamente
nel momento in cui persone lo buttano
nell'ambiente il problema si fa grosso e
come mi diceva un corano si sa bene che
fine facciano le queste questioni con
plastik quanti danni facciano
soprattutto dal punto di vista della
salute avrete visto sicuramente le foto
dei pesci con il ventre aperto piene di
plastica questo succede perché la
plastica nell'acqua galleggia il pesce
qualche altro organismo acquatico lo
scalo lo scambia per cibo se ne nutre
non sente più senso della fame e quindi
muore di fame
però questo pesce finisce anche nelle
nostre piatti sono siamo vegetariani o
vegani e quindi rischia di entrare in
circo anche nel nostro di corpo
sono tutte cose che ti butto lì
altro punto
questa è la scheggia impazzita che
nessun nessun probabilmente studio
metterà mai in
potrà mai calcolare perché è la mia
borsa della spesa che ho fatto dieci
anni fa che contenuti lizzare con mia
mamma che è una sorta sono molto
fortunato e che abbiamo riutilizzato la
borsa di un la stoffa di un ombrello
rotto io penso ma nessuno nessuno studio
dlc a me lo potrà mai confermare
probabilmente io penso che sia il
sistema più a basso impatto in assoluto
perché non ho riutilizzato nulla di
nuovo ho utilizzato una cosa che sarebbe
stata destinata all immondizia
indifferenziata attraverso
tutto questo per dirvi che
gli slogan non mi piacciono tanto e
dobbiamo continuare a porci delle
domande
dobbiamo continuare ad informarci da
fonti attendibili
dobbiamo essere
a essere bravi a capire chi è
attendibile chi no perché non è
assolutamente facile ma soprattutto
considera anche il fatto che la plastica
non è il male assoluto pensato agli
ospedali la plastica e salvavita e il
plastic free come abbiamo visto da
questi studi e da altri studi non sembra
la scelta migliore anche perché secondo
me il vero problema non è tanto
scegliere alla plastica con un altro un
altro materiale anche perché
spesso diventa un altro rifiuto noi
dovremo agire più radicalmente magari
diciamo a sostituendo la plastica
riusciamo a risolvere il problema e
dell'inquinamento del mare ma non
risolvere i problemi alla radice quelli
ambientali
quello che io
suggerisco è cercare di ridurre
il consumismo che è la nostra la nostra
economia si fonda sostanzialmente sul
consumismo più si consuma più se si
creano rifiuti più si crea un enorme
zaino ambientale di cose che poi vengono
buttate per cui riusciamo a cerchiamo di
riuscire a evitare il più possibile di
incorrere di rincorrere anche tutte le
varie
strand se dice così della del consumismo
quello che io
ipotizzo su cui sto lavorando in questo
periodo è il minimalismo che è il
contrario del consumismo è una cosa su
cui ci sto lavorando ci sta lavorando in
particolar modo adesso che sono in fase
di trasloco non c'è niente di meglio che
fare un trasloco per prendere coscienza
delle cose che riempiono la nostra casa
dopo nove anni sto cambiando casa e
quindi ed è un po di mesi che sto
cercando di selezionare cosa mi serve
davvero cosa e cosa invece non ha più
bisogno è un lavoro che parte
innanzitutto da noi stessi a un lavoro
difficile di presa di consapevolezza ma
il minimalismo ci permette di ridurre
veramente ciò che abbiamo in casa e ciò
che entra in casa e questo significa di
ridurre l'impatto ambientale
in maniera seria
pensate adesso natale si sta avvicinando
e essere minimalista natale credo che
sia il momento più difficile di tutto
l'anno
vuoi perché numerosi dei regali che
facciamo vuoi per i numerosi regali che
riceviamo che magari non sono neanche
spesso apprezzati e che a breve o tardi
diventano poi nei rifiuti
quindi io suggerisco il minimalismo
innanzitutto per il pianeta però ci fa
tantissimo bene anche a noi stessi
perché ci prende coscienza dei nostri
veri bisogni di ciò che veramente ci
dona benessere e questo ci permette
anche di di avere un migliore rapporto
con gli altri con noi stessi e con gli
altri e ci permette di selezionare di
fare spazio le cose che rendono la
nostra vita veramente degna di essere
vissuta che non è fatta né di cotone né
di plastica grazie
[Applauso]